employment ministers meeting in  luxembourg on thursday are expected to  further strengthen cooperation in the  fight against undeclared work  they will reach a general approach on a  decision establishing a platform to  improve cooperation at eu level in order  to more effectively prevent and deter  undeclared work  this platform where all member states  would be represented aims to facilitate  the exchange of best practices and  information and promote joint actions  between the different national  enforcement authorities  the council will also focus on the  midterm review of the eu 2020 strategy  including the evaluation of the european  semester  the strategy contains five headline  goals which represent objectives on  employment innovation education social  inclusion and climate and energy  ministers will also endorse a joint  opinion on the employment and social  protection committees as well as key  messages for the 2015 annual growth  survey  you